[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
and i hate this cheap at you and after a
while the baby was asleep and said [ __ ]
i'm gonna go outside and get some sun
and write some jokes and i'm writing
some joes
and all of a sudden this [ __ ] chiba
chew just [ __ ] overwhelms me
just [ __ ] overwhelms me right
and i had smoked some bot and i actually
put my head back and i'm like wow
i love when you get like that it had to
be about 10 after fall and i put my head
back
and all of a sudden i heard like excuse
me and i look up i'm like this [ __ ]
salesman and i look up and it's bergy
our friend bergy the armenian
he's like what are you doing i'm like
bergy i am [ __ ] up you know and he
proceeds to tell me a story about his
brother's arm is stuck like this forever
he has to
you know his mother has to put like a
[ __ ] pocket over here so you keep his
hand in there but his hand is like this
you know i'm like did you get him a cape
you know and i'm [ __ ] but the funny
thing was he was telling me a story
about his brother it's like anybody else
telling you
or story about their family that has a
disability you know and at first you
want to keep it as serious as you can
but i'm going down deep with this cheebo
true deca i just burst out [ __ ]
laughing
and it was so overwhelming that i burst
out laughing i almost fainted
because i was so embarrassed that i was
laughing that it lifted everything the
anxiety level yeah but i couldn't keep a
straight and he kept going like yeah he
has to keep his arm like this and my
mother made a jacket from to stick his
arm in
and i like napoleon yeah and i'm [ __ ]
freaking i'm surprised you like you let
him keep telling you
you have at least one cape in your
closet i know you i know i love them you
have a cape somewhere wait what happened
to capes when did they fall out when
these [ __ ] idiots start wearing tight
jeans caves have been around forever
there's no way you if you can't sling
dick on a cape you ain't slinging dick i
wonder how haven't you been married
i don't have a cape
my cape game sucks you get a black cape
with a red interior i'm getting a purple
cape get a black cape with a red
interior and one night go leanne i'll be
right back and come back balls ass naked
underneath and coming like this like a
heavy bella like bella lugosi and 52 god
naked with the cape they go [ __ ]
bananas women love [ __ ] capes capes
are so functional like if you got cold
i'd have a quilt cape so like almost
like a snuggie so i could just wrap up
in it
oh i love a [ __ ] cape the situation
to me feels like this
you ever have that girl from your days
in college she keeps in touch with you
yeah and every time you go to tampa
you take her out to dinner with her
husband
and your wife and you're looking at it
and and the whole time you're all
giggling hahaha drinking whatever wine
but you're looking at that [ __ ] going
and when i used to tie you up and make
you suck my balls like a savage
because you're looking at him he's like
he's kissing her and you're like
she used to lick my [ __ ] with that
tongue and they're at the table
we love each other yeah she loved me too
so i whipped it with a belt and made a
[ __ ] hummus off my nutsack
that you know what i'm saying like you
you know you won
like this guy's trying to be a nice guy
he's like well shut up doug i used to
[ __ ] her in the ass with egg yolks
at the same time
i'm saying when you do that then you
come see me you're over there playing
like you believe this [ __ ] dirty
horse he's an animal
i got two neighbors to the cops and the
other neighbors slash his aunt and i
talk to her every [ __ ] day really
yeah so we're good to go you come to my
house looking for problems
you're gonna leave there a limp and
[ __ ] i'll tell you that much
i think about that i think about someone
i just got guns i gotta go yeah oh no i
gotta uh you just sit there all night
like dude i have a joke i have a joke
about it in my act about there's no
better feeling than drinking with your
gun in the middle of the night just
waiting for [ __ ] to go down
two in the morning with a glock on your
lap just going come on [ __ ] make
sure that [ __ ] don't go off by mistake i
don't put bullets in my gun
get the magazine out of it when you're
something crazy when i took the life
insurance exam you take one over the
phone and the guy the kid answers the
phone and he goes i'm gonna walk you
through all the questions they ask you
if you've ever done drugs if you've ever
drank alcohol i get done all my
questions and and he goes uh
he goes okay i think we're done for now
i'm gonna end the recording i went oh
thank you and he does recording goes it
was a pleasure meeting the machine and i
was like [ __ ]
i just i'm sure he listened to my
answers like i very seldomly drink
i've never tried drugs or whatever my
[ __ ] you know remember the whole
green bay improv
no they used to be a green bay improv
for real yeah who goes to it
[Laughter]
you know in the summertime they're not
gonna go watch you yeah and in the
wintertime they're eating cheese
watching the [ __ ] packers
i think about it yeah when was the last
time you went to green bay did they all
had i remember go ahead give me time
no they don't want to know about comedy
they just want to tackle people
they tackle you at the airport in green
bay nobody goes to green bay have you
ever thought about that dude you know
when was the last time you talked to
anybody who said i did this theater in
green bay and it was fantastic i'm doing
green bay on this tour are you really
yeah it's the first time yeah i love
never i've never been i've never been to
green bay in my life
i took a fall out in october yeah and
they actually had the balls to do a
sunday show
the neighborhood kids know you're not
from labor and they try to chase you and
[ __ ] they try to intercept your shipment
it's worse than the drug business it was
like being narcos when i was [ __ ] 10
delivering papers it was like being
narcos i swear to god because they
dropped the paper off on the bottom of
five corners
believe it or not there's a place in my
hometown that's got five or six corners
six it's impossible to believe it's a
bagel shop
a bank
a thrifty store
another [ __ ] refrigeration store and
another corner over here five corners
yeah it's fine and as a matter of fact i
robbed the bank
in there when i was
it was a drive-through and we took it in
the weird kids
sunday night was the punch lines and
monday nights was cobs when that scumbag
was up there and he would make you sign
your name on a list and he wouldn't tell
you what time you go up and then he'd
just come up to you and tap you on the
shoulder you know how many comics flew
into that open mic and he didn't put up
you know he told you on the phone he was
who was this
he quit
he quit he was an old guy that ran cobbs
real prick and he was the one that told
ralphie
why did joe take ari and me on the road
that we were worthless and we used to
bust joe's balls and he had a crush on
joe because one day duncan and ch and
ari went downstairs to the radio with
joe
and that guy purposely brought a
two-seater
and he told ari and duncan he couldn't
go
so ralphie told me the story i told joe
joe was like come on the guy wouldn't
say that i always knew the guy was a
closet [ __ ] for stratus
so for months every time we go to cobbs
i tell him how's your friend joe i would
just torment joe joe you know he wants
to suck your dick like when he would
come up i go joe you want me to stay
like i would just you know like you want
me to say yeah you want me to say i
don't know what's going on between you
two and joe's he's not a gang a dog
trust me
i know but that dude was a scumbag
this [ __ ] 74 year old guy i grew up
in his house
so when i looked at the thing it's a no
caller id on it so i i thought it was my
uncle he's like well theo what's
happening and he goes what are you
[ __ ] talking about carmine
i go hey mr b what's going on he goes
i've been i've had something on my mind
for the last three days i really want to
tell you
i go what's up
and he goes uh
the other night i'm i'm uh eating
[ __ ] whatever dinner i'm by myself
and i see that this de niro
stallone movie's coming on so i say what
the [ __ ] let me watch it so i start
watching a movie and you pop up and joey
my world stop
because the dish fell out of my [ __ ]
hand
he goes i had seen you in that movie the
longest mile
whatever the [ __ ] that was
but this is real he goes and he was
hysterical you with that [ __ ] half a
homo adam sandler
like ari said to me the other day oh
you're gonna be in new york for danny
brown's show i'll come up to
williamsburg there's a barbecue place
where people stand on the line for an
hour oh [ __ ] you're not gonna see me
there yeah you're not gonna see me there
unless i get a jewish [ __ ] gold chain
i get one of those neck braces
like phil leotardo and the sopranos
after he got rear-ended remember he wore
a neck brace that's extra money because
the neck brace makes you cut the line
people feel bad for you you look like a
dog with you and you close one eye
don't wait in line so [ __ ] the dad
comes back to like an hour late i'm
watching tv and the dad comes back there
with a margarine tub
filled with water
remember the old margarine tubs in the
80s yes yeah yeah filled with water with
a little dish with cocaine floating on
it
okay
because in his mind
if the cops came in he would take the
dish and throw the coke in the water and
so now
listen to me he comes back there and as
soon as he comes back there he starts
sliding down things you know miami yeah
they have the slide down [ __ ] windows
like this just in case there's a
hurricane or something like that
yeah
he's so now i'm thinking this guy's
gonna [ __ ] me in the ass he's coming in
here with this tub of coke
and he's going to [ __ ] me in the ass
this is why they kept saying don't hang
out with muneco when he gets coked up
and this is after he asked you to kill
somebody this is yeah like this whole
like an hour after he asked me to
[ __ ] if i could go to the mafia and
get this girl killed
but
the more coke he did the creepier he got
not sexually he just got creepier and
more paranoid so the last thing he did
was he put boxer underwear on and he had
a 38 and he put the 38 he mangled it the
38 and he would have chancled on those
cuban chunks
would the wife be the late chichi and he
would just walk around like paranoid
like and look from window to window even
though the blinds were metal and they
were shut over the windows yeah he kept
looking at him and the [ __ ] gun kept
falling out of his underwear hitting the
floor and i'm like oh no
oh no and bert after the third time the
gun went off and he shot his foot by
this time it's seven in the morning he's
bleeding
and he's not even like like i would have
been on the floor like a [ __ ] ah
he's like don't worry about don't worry
about his wife and his daughter his son
hear the gun go off
they run back there and they're like oh
no he did it again
i go should i call the ambulance it
sounds like he's going to be fine he
does this like every month the doctor
came it was the eighth time he shot
himself in the [ __ ] foot he had no
foot left i kept looking at his one foot
and i kept seeing like little holes i
thought he stepped on something on the
swim from cuba or something like this
[ __ ] iphone when somebody calls it
beeps but it doesn't tell you who called
okay doesn't tell you who's calling me
so i have to hang up with the person and
wait five minutes and
the call comes through
so i have to shut the thing off and
maybe start it you'll tell me how to do
it and my [ __ ] other thing keeps
asking me to upgrade
and every time i hit it 10 pop-ups come
on i don't understand this [ __ ]
happening
so you know i gotta have apps i don't
[ __ ] get it just one time hit me and
then move on with your life every 10
weeks they want me to upgrade and do
this get the [ __ ] out of here so
you mean you're not gonna wait in line
for that new iphone oh yeah i'll be
there tomorrow morning nice and early
like a [ __ ] half a [ __ ] [ __ ]
i got better things to [ __ ] do with
my time than wait there so i could have
the phone first i can tell my idiot
buddies i have it oh you're so lucky
cause you're still gonna win like a
[ __ ] [ __ ] yeah that's great
what was i talking about about something
they got your high going so you should
just get a homeless guy to stand in line
for you just go hey man you're outside
anyway
they would give him 20 bucks an hour
like that's what real pep would do but
these [ __ ] idiots can't figure that
out god forbid they can't stay outside
and tell themselves stories about
[ __ ] alana del rey or whatever the
[ __ ] these kids talk about
hillsboro had a gang called twt together
we thump
and now there you did not [ __ ] with
hillsborough hillsborough was like
[ __ ] scary but robinson was in our
they were like yeah there's a little
south tampa
and we had we had two crew we had two
gangs that gangs that's really i'm
really overstating it one was a gang
they were called the cavemen and there
was like all it was all preppy white
boys i was not a part of the cavemen and
then my school had this
it was more like a club on campus but we
would fight together and we would call
it epu the pluribus unum you know you
know your your gang is not tough when
it's named after the thing on the penny
at blur bazoona monty together we're one
or whatever something
but yeah i remember i remember fights i
remember not being afraid of fights now
i look at fights i'm terrified of them
but i remember in high school just being
like fight let's do it grab a golf club
[ __ ] grab a baseball bat
my buddy weicho got hit in the head with
a steel pipe one night
now i look at it and go
what a [ __ ] lunatic would swing a
steel pipe at someone's head
but back then you're just like
[ __ ] happens
you know it's like i think that's why
i'm most afraid of young kids like
people go
are people that are racist i go no i'm
more ageist like i don't want young kids
around me young kids terrify me because
they don't have they don't feel like
there's any repercussion in life all
your dirt you did that was horrific
happened when you were young
you know when you just figured oh life
will never end and then you get older
and you're like
i would love five more years you know
for like like i started looking at it
going like [ __ ] where did it all go
like did i really just drink from
[ __ ] age 20 or 20 to 45 you know i
don't remember anything
[Music]
[Music]
it's a dark place
[Music]